the Joe Rogan experience she's talking
about putting on a fight on April 18th
you know I don't know how they're gonna
do that I don't know if they're gonna be
able to do that in the United States
they're talking about doing it in a
place with less than ten people and then
you know they're just an open arena I
guess someone's gonna commentate it so
I'm gonna be me and they're gonna be
duking it out like in an empty place and
they're gonna try to do that on the 18th
they did it for the last card in Brazil
because it was ordered by the government
the government ordered all large
gatherings to break up when they started
seeing the cases of Corona rising in
Brazil so they had to do the Brazil card
indoors no people weird so but they're
gonna plan khabib and Tony this way
they're gonna plan it so it doesn't even
have to be a big place they could do it
like a film studio like legitimately
they could sit they could set this up in
a film studio somewhere I mean they
could Tyler Perry's got a place in
Florida they look good on a Florida rent
one of Tyler Perry's gigantic film
studios set up I mean we did it in when
we did the fight for the troops when
they did yeah yeah San Diego and several
other places in Austin as well whenever
we did it there's a few more there´ll I
know there's a few different ones that
we did they just would use an airplane
hangar and the troops be there that they
would be the whole audience with the
troops and their uniforms and they would
set up this octagon in an airplane
hangar and it was pretty powerful it's
different different real different
different kind of show but they could do
that they could do that in a studio or
just a large warehouse the UFC could do
it set up some lights have some crazy
high-speed hook up to the Internet well
it's party notes getting uploaded and
we're watching it from here I mean that
they could definitely do that the UFC
has the capability of doing that the
thing is how they gonna make sure that
nobody has it you know you're gonna have
to test everybody and if someone has it
do you let them fight like what if they
have it and they're like Idris Elba they
have no sense
but they got the corona like what if
khabib as the corona or what if tony has
the corona just khabib even fight him
this fight is so [ __ ] cursed this
place I gotta be honest with you I gotta
be honest with you I already that's the
one of the first things I thought of
would say started talking then they
start talking about the NBA games like
well this feels this is why Dana's
trying so hard to make it happen even if
there's only ten people in a room at
first for a couple days that was mad at
Dana my [ __ ] day now I go you know
what this fight has to happen this I
don't care if this happens by itself in
a [ __ ] airport in Havana Cuba mmm I
don't give a [ __ ] but this fight has to
get over with we've waited so long
how many cancellations three quite a few
3:40 this is the fourth time three or
four I think this is the fourth time
visits broken me yeah anxiety actually
might be the fifth this might be the fin
oh I think so yeah they find this
[ __ ] curse google it
how many times has Toni versus could be
been cancelled I'm gonna say I think
this is the fifth time it's many times
though and it's the best fight then they
they kept giving you know first the NBA
then the next tested positive yeah then
the [ __ ] city of New York went under
and I'm like all no everything's
pointing in the wrong direction
I go but don't have Vegas then Vegas
said then I [ __ ] March 20 this is the
fifth it's the fifth I walk in time come
on this has to happen it is the final
care about any other quite on the card
just pay them Dana just pay them just
one fight just pay them one fine I'll
pay the paper no warmups I'll pay the
6950 pay-per-view just to see khabib and
get it over with could you imagine
that's it nobody nobody else has to
fight 6900 one fight one two three
trainers in each corner that did eight
yeah one guy and we'll you'll put the
[ __ ] judges they watch from home
listen that terrible one there there
they tell me wonder they're terrible
when they're there
yes I'm gonna help them be in there
you oftentimes you honestly you get a
better view of what's going on when
you're watching at home okay so yeah
especially the headphones on so when I
watch with headphones because I'm
watching like when I look down at the
screen sometimes when I'm watching
fights I have to sometimes I get a
better view I can't see what the [ __ ] is
going on there's pillars in front of me
guys are grappling and I don't know if
someone's trying to get a submission or
what's happening sometimes guys tap and
I didn't even see it it was like what
did he what do you do I don't have to
like break it down then I have to look
at it on the screen when you're watching
at home often times you really have a
better view of it but this is doesn't
it's not as crazy right so we we don't
need them they're within social
distancing we already here you could put
them in a [ __ ] judges can all come right
here I'm gonna look over their shoulder
come right here and then so all we need
is the three guys in the corner yeah two
fighters the ref Bruce Buffer test Bruce
Buffer Bruce Buffer he could do it long
distance no no no he's gonna do with a
gas mask on Bruce proffer is gonna be in
there red face with a [ __ ] school but
helmet on does it have to be
pay-per-view do you think no yes listen
for it of course it does what are you a
communist no socialists trying to get
[ __ ] free show same time you're
talking about passing on stimulus checks
how are you the UFC wants money I'm sir
how are you gonna get people to pay for
you're gonna get plenty of people like I
said you know what same Jamie wants
everything to be somebody [ __ ] loses
here so you gotta be a douchebag
somebody loses out because how am I
gonna put all this there's three or four
prelims five free limbs and then four
fights before that so I'm talking ten
fights I'm talking twenty people three
per whatever their trainers that's a lot
of people Joe in one [ __ ] place a
winner so it can't we got to eliminate
their early prelims and just do the main
card they could do that for everybody
also I'd have to test everybody
everybody cannot share a space either I
cannot be in this room
with your romero without throwing a
sidekick he's about to fight but if
everybody's tested and everyone's
negative then who gives a [ __ ] that
should be the only thing like if you're
testing your negative but this should be
able to wander around
[Applause]